many argue today that the Constitution  is outdated because it addresses  problems peculiar to the 18th century  some parts of the Constitution do read  rather quaintly but consider the  injunction against titles of nobility in  article 1 section 9 of the Constitution  is that so outdated the purpose of that  injunction is to prevent the government  granting special privileges to some for  partisan reasons this strikes at the  heart of the rule of law the crony  capitalism so common today is a place  for the government bestows favours and  tax dollars on some businesses to give  them a leg up over others this is  exactly the kind of thing the  Constitution was meant to prohibit  perhaps the Constitution is not so  outdated after all learn more about the  Constitution at Constitution minute com  [Music]